hello everybody welcome to the first
feature special for anno 2205 this time
we're going to take a deeper look into
the multi-session gameplay and at the
region gameplay as well
the multi-session gameplay of anno 2205
consists of twelve sectors and all of
these sectors can be combined to one
gigantic endless game first there's the
nine player sessions that are divided
into three regions the temperate zone
the Arctic zone and the lunar zone on
moon and each of these can be obtained
by the player and he's free to choose
among the three sessions that are in
each sector and the other sessions which
he does not choose well he'll be able to
obtain these later in the game in
addition players will be able to enter
to crisis zones where optional military
conflicts are waiting to be solved
finally there's the space station
serving as an online hub hosting
different online features like the
council where players can cast their
vote and this makes a total of 12
sectors the biggest a no handles games
so far
let's take a closer look at the regional
gameplay of these zones first we go to
the temperate region in the temperate
regions the players will find their
homeland it's very familiar to them with
big mountains and green grass there they
can build the biggest metropolises and
raise giant bridges in the Arctic zone
it's really chilly and cold the players
will build their settlements and
colonies very different from the
temperate zone because their factory
outlets in the Arctic region they will
provide heat which their inhabitants
need so the players will place their
buildings around the facilities and this
will create a different look and a
different gameplay then last not least
the player makes his way up to the lunar
zone where obviously he has no
atmosphere so the conditions are quite
different from Earth he has to set up
shield generators to protect everything
he builds from meteor showers and build
up special buildings to save his
citizens from the radiation of their own
movement so it's the most hostile
environment but still a magical mystical
place for the player to set along the
multi-session gameplay of anno 2205
offers a lot of advantages for the
players for example their sessions they
are running in parallel so when the
player is in one session all the other
sessions he obtains are running in the
background and he is free to switch the
sessions whenever he wants he's not
forced to do it it's his decision the
most important part of it is that
everything the player builds is there to
last
he is never forced to leave behind his
creation if he starts a new game it's
his own decision but if he sticks to his
game and his cooperation he already set
up he can create a multi-million
metropolis in all the 12 sectors
offering the biggest endless game ever
and we will continue to expand this
gigantic Empire even more with the
season pass
coming up
I hope you enjoyed our first featured
special on multi-session gameplay for
Hannah 22:05 thanks for watching and see
you soon guys